nous sommes à la maison elsa triolet
aragon à saint-arnoult-en-yvelines où
vient tout juste de s'ouvrir
l'exposition consacrée à benjamin
vautier connu sous le nom d'artiste de
ben une exposition voulue à l'image
justement de cet artiste légère et
accessible mais qui vient secouer nos
certitudes
[Musique]
bonjour ben
l'exposition qui se déroule ici à la
maison elsa triolet aragon se déroule
jusqu'au 27 novembre en parallèle de la
rétrospective qui vous est consacrée au
musée maillol c'est à paris ça ce sera
jusqu'au mois de janvier cette
exposition ici vous l'avez appréhender
comment comme un parallèle un complément
moi j'étais naturel j'avais même pas
j'ai pas même pas beaucoup y penser on
va proposer une expo d'habitude
j'ai aimé l'idée d'exposer déchets à
elsa triolet aragon parce que
je me demande si c'est pas une
connotation intellectuelle qui me
servait à quelque chose ou pas mais ça
m'a plu et puis j'ai vu les dépliants il
ya eu mes amis monory compagnies qui ont
exposé ici donc je me suis dit c'est un
beau lieu mais savait pas qu'il y aurait
tellement le monde et je ne savais pas
que c'était si important que ça vous
bénéficiez l'immense notoriété on peut
le constater et pourtant justement parce
que ça fait quoi aussi à cette
exposition à votre travail même vous
avez vous dit vous avez déclaré
récemment pardon je ne voulais pas faire
ben ben vous dites aussi je déteste ben
et son ego absolument parce que c'est un
peu il est un peu un peu quelque chose
de moi c'est qu'un artiste en dix
rencontres que il est toujours à la
recherche de la gloire et est à la
recherche de lui même et à l'enjeu est
donc un moment donné ils s'aiment pas
beaucoup mais il peut pas faire
autrement c'est à lui on est pris dans
un piège dans un piège du moi
même vous même n'importe qui le matin
vous dites bajus que j'aurais bien voulu
devenir un vrai beau gosse mais je peux
pas
quelqu'un d'autre donc on est un
incident dans son moi donc il faut faire
avec il ya des moments où des piles de
l'idée du mois qui ne pensent que moi il
se débat aussi autour du mois du pouvoir
de l'argent aussi enfin c'est des choses
que vous avez abordé tout à leur moment
de la présentation il faut il faut être
essentielle se poser des questions et
mange à la rigueur
j'ai des amis sage dans laquelle les
gens bien prennent une belle ne sont pas
des hawks est bon oui c'est beau
magnifique ce beau succès là et en fin
de compte c'est
une expulsion dans lequel on est beau
contre j'aime jaldak dans le doute qui
est du doute qui est du doute donc on se
pose des questions sur la voilà alors à
la rigueur si le résultat est que les
gens vont partir d'ici en se disant benz
pose des questions sur lui même ça me
ferait plus plaisir que ledit qui pense
c'est un petit peu de temps ce qui qui
pensent tient ce qu'il appelle génial et
il suffit s'en vient sur ses oeuvres sur
ses inscriptions dollar et blanc aussi
est sur votre travail graphique tout ça
c'est connu par tout le monde ne serait
ce que parce que on le retrouve partout
sur des trousses les cahiers l'art est
partout finalement de toute façon c'est
l'image ses pieds c'était les gens
quoique
un moment donné j'étais dans des
galeries d'art contemporain et je me
vais compliqué même pièce et des
devenirs que chez le collectionneur au
quatrième étage sur un mur je me suis
dit non si la place est bonne il faut
qu'un enfant puisse la voile à l'école
il faut qu'eux mêmes et pour que ça
circule donc j'ai accepté l'idée du
produit dérivé
bien que c'est un piège de produits
dérivés c'est ça ou réduit à
une équipe a quelque chose de négatif
alors en fin de compte que les produits
dérivés je suis ni spa est un artiste
qui est uniquement positif et ça ce
n'est pas ben les jeux croit souvent que
l'humanité ne va pas le coup ce qui
prime en plus c'est le contenu puisque
la forme en fait finalement c'est le
contenu c'est le message à faire passer
c'est justement comment évoluer votre
oeuvre sur ces 50 60 dernières années et
quelles sont les problématiques que vous
vous posez aujourd'hui j'ai part précisé
mais en plus vous habitez sur l'iss nice
qui a été au coeur de l'actualité ces
derniers mois ça vous a fait évoluer
votre réflexion sur le message que
voulait faire passer oui le message que
je l'aimais peut passer par exemple par
rapport à ce qui se passe dans le monde
aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi c'est un mot
qui m'intéresse le pourquoi
pourquoi en arriver à tant de haine d'un
côté comme de l'autre beaucoup en
arriver à des six du mal et du bien
drôle donc si au moins on pouvait poser
des questions lancé le débat ce serait
positif pour la philosophie d'un peuple
d'une langue d'une culture c'est positif
je demandais pourquoi c'est le rôle de
l'art aussi non le vol de l'a
malheureusement ces amas tgv ça c'est
moi touche pas à monter les doigts je me
sais là dessus mais la panique on le
rôle de là c'est de poser des questions
mais on y l'artiste ne s'en aperçoit que
après parce que si on attise à bord du
nouveau par exemple demain matin vous
nous tuez être des plus vous mettez tout
et vous dites les tout bon et ça va
quand même poser une question est ce que
les tous deux ou comment vous
appelez-vous est où sont ils vraiment de
la wii alors ils sont pas mal c'est tout
donc vous paie d'avancé le schmilblick
quand même mais en fait ce n'est pas le
but du voc buts à gogo le cas où c'est
de pouvoir payer tout et qu'on parle de
retour on conclure l'entretien qu'elle
oeuvre vous n'avez pas encore réalisé
vous auriez envie de réaliser un jeu
peut pas ou le disque souple et qu'on va
s'arrêter là et ce sera l'occasion
d'entendre une autre fois merci beaucoup
merci au revoir merci